外したちょっと正木取締役ですはい皆様 t シャツアレンジというものをご存知
でしょうか
知ってますかあんまりよくわからない実は僕もなんですよ
堅物で色々調べてみたんですけどもう使わなくなった t シャツとか皆さん持ってる
と思います持ってないに停車と様待ってるのがもったいないということで
ではなくなったりした t シャツをアレンジして別の使い方を
しようということが示唆されるというものらしいですまことに t シャツアレンジと
言ってもいろんなのがあって足ときってみてビックリしたり鳥元がヒロミを小さくして
みたり
g 名を入れてちょっと4世駆使したり腕のそれをめっちゃ短くしてみたり
問題がタンクトップドライにしてるのもありましたリメイクしてバックにしたにあっ
クッションカバーまあそう言ってに使わなくなった t シャツおり名
ですてとにかく他のいろんなことにいつか9ミリっていうのは t シャツリメイク
ところでございますで今回なんですけども企画として我々も t 室でメイクをして
みようということで切ってつなげて
[音楽]
つけど
ディスプレイ09:00
まったくを覚えるかもなかった本来アレンジする t シャツは僕論壇ずを開発して
いる株式会社偶然りさんから提供していただきますご覧傾斜とかこうしても良いと言わ
れているので今回この t シャツ使ってる実は連城やっていこうと思いますね
ちょっとここで本日お話があるんですけども何件シャツは恋情するかというと我々の t
シャツですよね
まあ意味深にちょっとをそろえたという
たと言っていますが爆場所は動画の最後でちょっというお知らせがあるので是非最後で
見てください
実施されちゃってるわけなんですけども要するにあるでしょ
斬新な提出は h した人数
はいはぁっはぁっはぁっ芸術系な十分こちらも梅喧続けるので1方が来てくれている
ことができるのかなと思ったんだよ
[音楽]
温まるよ
tan
井田タッチせよいい
ついて
一の放ってるわって
あってもこれ見た完全に剥がすと安全
ん
あえて言うけど無事警察は連続作り終わりましたねえと僕とは月それぞれ2つずつ作品
をつくったのね
それを今から2人ずつ校に紹介していってどれが一番斬新でクリエイティビティな作品
なのかを決めていきたいとおもいます
まず最初は正木ですどうぞ
[音楽]
電王を
テーマはワイルドだぜマルクじゃなくて吹いネックにしたのと
ここに
切り込みを入れて
ワンポイントのワイルドさをアピールした男性向けのアレルギー t シャツですね
いっ
立っ
ああっ
夏とかでも良さそうですよねこれからの暑い時期だしてい
来ないですか
したと相まってバスケっぽいなぁバスケっぽいね全然秋山へアジアにあるじゃ結構結果
である
あっつどうぞ
ame
ザウスんでしょ
また分まあ見てもらったら分かると思うんですけども v ネックですね
あのサイトにも書いてあったんですよ思い切って振りにいくにしましょう
はぁたちから思い切ってびっくりしてみました男性だけじゃなくて女性にも来てもらい
たいと思って
いつでも授業ができる
ンこっちからマイケル c こっちから振って税の授乳方法があるって凄い
なかなかやっぱ普通のデザイナーが思いつかない
私かねぱっと見でも
これではでは続いては3作品で正樹さんですどうぞ
今度はう
[音楽]
ブーブー夏けど色々 soyjoy よく
よく見たらなんかコスちらみたいな加須そうそういいねというが立ってるよ
ちょっとセクシー音です実際に切ってみたらどうですかね
午前23よねはいはい
先ほど飾ってくれよ見せてください皆にしてるんじゃないよ
とりあえず柄薄くん
なんか森で木に引っ掛かっ
だよください数です+を飾ってくれる一さんの作品です
どうぞ
3位
[音楽]
バッハ
うっぱ
けっこうすごいと思うんだけどメーカーが鎧を作ろうと思ったんですけどこれが限界で
去ったぶー
って言うまでも t シャツでできてるって言われないとわかんないよねまあ確かに
もうほぼ心に額もいいすごいから抜けぱ
強そうかと言われるっつっ
いるよ
うわぁ
あの実際やってみたんですけど結構難しかったですなかなか綺麗にできるって言うので
来なかったんで是非皆さんもチャレンジしてみてください
それが良かったかちょっとポイント等で描いてみてください今回のこの t シャツの
動画ですねぼく物価下コラボしたんですけども
ポコロンダンジョンズさんとのコラボ企画でございますそして心旦那さん3周年県で
ございましたおめでとうございます
ポコロンダンジョンズ3周年記念ということで今回なんと今僕が来ていること
ポコロンダンジョンズの和美社長のコラボ t シャツを
333名の方にプレゼントいたします
はい nmb で僕が2死ぬって周りにはキャラクターがいますその子さん前は子連れ
のサイン入りの t シャツになります
なかなか悪くないか色合いも口がさんと僕のエンディングっぽくなっておりますたい
ときで動画のあるような今回のキャンペーンの url 貼っておくのでぜひ一つら
から応募してみてください
とすると3周年キャンペーン期間中はポロだぞ無料で最高齢
登ったらてにある箇所が回せるので是非この機会にダウンロードしてみてはいかが
でしょうか
じゃーん
me
あっはぁ